I'm joking firmly I'm a software
engineer at SIBO technologies and today
I will be talking about Scala dia cells
and probabilistic programming so my
Scala DSL I mean domain-specific
language so just as a little outline of
my talk first I'll talk about
probabilistic programming and span and
Scala Stan then I'll talk about
advantages of doing this in an embedded
the main specific language and finally
I'll talk about how we do that within
the Scala type system if you have any
questions feel free to stop me at any
time I think we have a small enough
group here that I can probably take
questions so from a programmers
perspective if I'm given this task of
predicting weight from height and I have
this set of data how would I go about
that well it looks like it might be
aligned I mean maybe a pretty poor line
but let's say we try to fit that to a
line so we say that we have weight is
some intercept alpha plus some beta
times your height and we think that that
might be here weight of course it's not
exactly right because there's a little
bit of error around each of these points
obviously so maybe we say there's some
modeling error measurement error and
that we model is Epsilon and we say that
epsilon is some drawn from some normal
distribution centered around zero with
some Sigma and so what we've really done
here is we've created a generative model
of creating weights from Heights so
given any weight I can create give you
are given any height I can give you a
weight that this model predicts it's
it's not perfect but it'll do something
perhaps and we've done this completely
in a completely generative way I haven't
actually done any math to do it and so
ideally I'd like to just give this to a
computer and say hey solve this problem
for me I this is my model give me the
answer and so that's what we would hope
to do and that would be called inference
and so how would I do that inference so
it turns out that there's this really
nice programming language called Stan
it's a probabilistic programming
language and it allows you to take these
generative models and the sampling and
it gives you answers I I really like
Stan because I as a programmer I think
this is the way I think I write my
program and it gives me my answer it's
not like I do any statistical anything
it's just here's a generative model give
me the answer I highly recommend
checking out the stan user's guide and
reference manual it's quite
comprehensive and it's about you know
600 pages but not only does it have a
complete description of the stained
language but it's also got lots of
examples and pitfalls of how to use Stan
okay so if we go back to my example of
predicting weight we have our weight
drawn our weight is some intercept times
its slope times height plus an epsilon
and we can rewrite that just to be a
little sin otherwise its equivalent with
which is weight is drawn from a normal
distribution centered around alpha plus
beta times height and there's some error
for each of those points and so how
would we take this and give it to Stan
so that Stan could give us the answer
for it what alpha and beta is Sigma
should be so that we can you know use
this for actually doing predictions and
so that's what we'll do here so this is
just Scala code to represent this
problem we have our training data
represented as n which is the number of
data points height is a vector of at
length n which is the heights of each
person or whatever weight is another
vector at length on and then we have
parameters that we want to learn and
thus there are Alpha Beta Sigma
which is alpha is some parameter there's
a real betas are real and Sigma is also
a real but got a lower bound to 0
because can't have a negative standard
deviation and finally we have the model
so it's basically the same as the math
notation slightly more verbose
wait is that tilde operator drawn from a
stand normal distribution center to
alpha plus beta times height and Sigma
and this is valid Scala code it's
actually Scala Stan and of course we
could also add more to this like a prior
say if we want to be Bayesian and say
that this is what our prior belief is so
a prior is just I don't know like if
you're given the absence of data what
what is my belief of what the data
should be in the prior tries to capture
this so in this case we're saying that
Sigma is probably 0 like we would hope
that the error is close to 0 and there's
lots of literature on trying to figure
out what the best priors are this Stan
wiki has this prior choice
recommendations which really gives you a
lot of useful information there but you
could run this without the prior but it
would it be less efficient so it's kind
of useful to have a prior so anyway if
we run this program and we get these
results so we're just saying that we
want to substitute our data that were
given and then run the program our Stan
program and then we get these results
and this is printing the actual weight
on the x-axis and their predicted weight
along the y-axis and we can see that
there's some error associated with that
so it's not a perfect model and of
course if you look carefully there's
actually more than one prediction per
actual point
these are draws from the posterior
distribution so this is a really cool
thing about Bayesian
methods like this is that it doesn't
just give you a point estimate of what
the result should be it gives you a
whole distribution and you can use a
point estimate like the best value are
the map but you could also use the
distribution to say well is it really a
wide distribution or am i really certain
of am I really certain of the result and
it tells you all that of course there's
Thomas Bayes okay so we look at this
model and we're like well it kind of
works but it kind of doesn't so what
what can we do to make it better well in
this particular data set we also have
the gender of the participants so maybe
we can make use of that somehow so what
if we how can we put that into our model
and so there are lots of ways you can
imagine doing this this is one of them
that I came up with really quick just
how about different intercept and slope
for each gender so there's alpha and
beta are two alphas and two betas and
we're saying that maybe the Sigma is the
same because well maybe I don't know
there's the same error process for the
both of those still implementing this of
course is pretty straightforward you
just added an array that has which
gender each of the data points is and
then we make of each of our parameters
of vector instead of real and then the
model is actually pretty simple too we
just say for each alpha we index it by
the gender of that particular point and
that silly will start : star thing is
just element wise multiplication now how
many of you are familiar with Scala our
breeze but that's it's pretty similar
okay so yeah the question was what do I
mean by elementwise multiplication so
beta gender is actually a vector of
length N and height is a vector of
length n and is returning a vector of
length n okay so we run that model and
and of course it's a little better but
still not perfect I mean there are lots
of things we could try throwing in here
and redoing a slightly different model
say I don't know putting some lighting
latent things in there but I guess that
kind of gets the point across that it's
you can play around with it that's it's
pretty simple so that's that's Stan our
scholars Stan really but as you've
noticed that's actually and Scala not
and Stan and I haven't even shown you
what Stan looks like yet so why would we
do it in Scala so now I'll talk about
the advantages of an embedded DSL so I
guess first you might ask well what
isn't in better DSL well it's pretty
simple really the program is in another
program is inside the program so it's
like putting a stand program inside a
Scala program it's simple so if you are
familiar with Stan are using it in other
context like an Python or are you what
you do is you take the text version of
the stand code and you reference it in
your are code you can do that either by
loading a file or by concatenating
strings together but of course that can
get messy but it's nice that you can
reuse the same stand code in multiple
places of course there are lots of
advantages of to actually embedding it
rather than just using string
concatenation for example I don't know
if if you use if you're familiar with
Scala how many here are familiar with
Scala just good makes this a lot easier
so
a lot of times you will use an IDE well
you don't have to but it makes life
simpler and you can get this
discoverability like you especially if
you don't know Stan you can start typing
and you get like all the different
distributions that are available to you
and they're alright as far as I know
there aren't any Stan IDs so this is
really a nice thing that you get for
free by implementing it in Scala it's
type safe so it would also be type safe
to do this since Dan but if you were
doing loading it from a file it would
give you the the error would be on the
in the file that you loaded or if you
were concatenating strings together to
build up your program the error would be
in some line number that was meaningless
because you were concatenating strings
but if you're using an embedded DSL the
compiler will tell you hey the error is
right here and that's actually where the
air is which is kind of nice the
interface is type safe so in the our
world or Python world you would have to
say oh I have variable X and it's a
vector but what if you got the name X
wrong there's nothing preventing you
from doing that you could say variable Z
and it's not doesn't even exist in that
in in the Stan program nothing but then
it just fails at runtime here it tells
you that you have to have the right
argument so here for example not only do
we need to know the name of the type the
argument but we also have to know the
type so here we're passing in a 1 for
our vector but one isn't a vector so
it's a type error it's kind of magic
composable so we can build up multiple
programs and programs just by sticking
existing ones together you can do that
with string concatenation too it just
gets really messy really quick here we
have a regression model and then we have
a Bayesian regression model which is our
regression we had before a simplified
version of it actually and then a normal
prior and then we can just create
our final model that's just new Bayesian
regression with normal prior and we can
build up all kinds of complicated things
like this we could put
priors on the parameters for example
maybe one is a shrinkage prior on there
or something that all kinds of things
and finally it's we can compute on the
stand model so this is actually
something I'm just starting to play with
a little bit more but it's really cool
because you can give it this you can
give Scylla Stan your stand model and
then you can actually do computations on
for example optimization so there's a
Stan log eat some exp function which is
way faster than this log Stan of doing
Stan exp a plus Stan exe P but I don't
necessarily know about that when I'm
coding it up and I might maybe it I
think it's too ugly to write it this way
or something who knows but I can write
an optimization stage they'll just give
this to me for free which is really cool
you can also do some kind of linting
stuff like if i forget to put a lower
bound on Sigma it'll actually the model
will work fine but it just won't be very
efficient because it'll sample outside
the range all the time so hopefully I've
convinced you that embedding this DSL is
a good thing to do and you know
probabilistic programming of course is
awesome so how do we do that that's so
the first thing we have to do is stage
using stage the Stan computations using
types use type members for building
complex Stan types and then we use
implicit s-- for enforcing type safety
and then abstract interpretation for
actually doing linting and optimization
type things
okay so staging so the way this works is
they have these stand pipes which are
not necessarily line up don't
necessarily line up with scala types
unfortunately so we have for example
Stan int stand vector stand real and we
our types actually are our type members
of this other thing that I'll get to
later but you don't actually have to
worry about this because it's all and
type inferred the types actually is more
complicated in that previous tree have
all kinds of things like row vectors and
vectors and matrices and this allows us
to do all kinds of cool type checking
and prevent problems early on so create
those we just do int and it creates a
stand int and create an array events by
calling this apply method on it which
creates a new type that's an array of
Stan int and you can do some cool things
type magic with this so the way this
works is we have we keep track of the
type and stand int and then apologize
for all the nonsense here but lots of
type type nonsense then we just create
the array with the contained in so we
can just create arbitrarily complex
array structures like this clear yeah
so then values are have some type so
that's the outer part is the value part
so we have a stand data declaration
which is our input to the stand program
of Stan ants and we create that with
data int same with parameters and of
course when we run the program here has
like alpha plus beta that just creates a
new stand pipe that has the right type
so we've gotten to the point where we
have all these data type these values of
Stan types voting around but now we want
to actually make sure that they're valid
because we want to prevent compile
errors and Stainland we want to make
them show up in Scotland so for example
we have this division of a scalar by a
vector and we don't want to allow that
on the other hands we do want to allow
dividing a vector by a scalar so how do
we do that so we if you try to come up
with a method signature for divide it
might look like this but that doesn't
prevent us from doing anything so
implicit is everyone here familiar with
implicit SAR how big scary concept I
know it's probably one of the most
unique things I think of Scala and I'm
not familiar of many other languages
that actually have it if any they're
scary and I guess not scary as macros
say but they're they're very powerful
and it turns out we can make pretty good
use of them here so back to our example
with the scalar divided by a vector we
just put this implicit on there it's
another argument list and saying hey
compiler give me an implicit that proves
to me that I can do this
and so in this case the father is like I
don't like that doesn't exist you can't
do that so it says the vision is not
allowed you can't divide an INT by a
vector so type classes just a quick
walkthrough of the way implicit swirl
for the in case you're not familiar so
you have a class my type class T which
is T is the type parameter and then you
have an object that which is the
companion object it's just static for
Java people there's an implicit value of
my int in there that is of type my class
int and then we can divide define these
functions on that take this implicit and
when this is an equivalent syntax so the
first fun we have it takes a X of type T
the T will be inferred because it's a
type parameter and then we have this
implicit evidence as the second argument
list and we can provide it in the in the
program but we don't have to the power
of the let in if it can and if it can
we're able to call that method just fine
the fun too is just the synthetic sugar
for the same thing and if we call fun
for it finds my int and everything's
happy if we call fun four point five
there's no instance of my type class
double and it blows up of course there
are other places you can put implicit so
I won't get into the whole the whole
thing but this is basically how Scala
Stan implements its implicit our type
checking
okay so if we look back to our
type-checking example here's another one
so we want to say what how does this
multiplication work so we have an X
that's a data vector n beta that's real
and then we have multiplication that's
real times a vector and we have this
implicit multiplication allowed and we
have here's the definition of that and
then there's actually an implicit def
for a scalar and the compound type which
includes a vector and so that works just
fine
any questions
and that's cool I'm Lincoln and this is
used all over the place and Palestine
which is huge file that has basically
all the rules of how all the different
operators work and how the functions
work because this is just a very generic
way of doing that but you can also do
other fun things with implicit so random
number generation and Stan takes on a
whole different works differently than
in other languages
perhaps so the way it works is you have
a distribution so normal and we want to
draw numbers around the numbers from
that normal distributions and you just
do normal 0 1 and this gives you random
number draws from that distribution
unfortunately unfortunately you can only
use random numbers in certain places and
Stan programs I guess they kind of want
the model to be deterministic if the
model is not deterministic it's hard to
do any optimization or sampling from it
this doesn't make sense so you can only
use this in certain places in fact you
can only use it and transform data so
that's like before the program runs it
transforms all your data are and
generated quantities blocks which is
like an output that runs after your
model has run so we can use implicit to
enforce scope so our random number
generator takes this random number
generator available implicit and then we
just have a single instance of this and
inside the scopes where it's allowed to
call that we make the implicit available
and so now when you try to call random
numbers from inside a model which isn't
allowed it says it's not allowed
more uses for implicit use we can check
the input data this has a scary n-type
signature to it I have a declaration so
we can set the input data for Stan data
declarations and the data type that
depends on the type of declaration and
so here we have an implicit D whatever
that silly operators called t pound
scala type and that's a type projection
saying the scala type member of T which
is a seka double in the vector case we
this this implicit is only exists when
that is true so it only exists if V is a
subtype of T scholar
and in this particular case we have a
seek of 1 2 3 and that is a subtype of T
spawn double so it works now if we try
to pass the wrong thing in there we have
T is stand double again and V is int but
int is not a subclass of seek of double
and we get a compile time error
so that's cool and we can get like 90%
of the way to proving that all stamp
programs are thou are all Scala Stanton
programs are valid Stan programs you
just using these kinds of techniques but
we can't get all the way there
unfortunately so there are some things
like break and continue statements which
are much more difficult to handle so for
example it looks really scary to perhaps
a scala programmer to see a break
statement in the for loop but like that
doesn't even exist what are you talking
about here but it's Stan you can't have
breaks and so it's just a function that
break out a loop but it doesn't work
when you're not in a loop so can we make
sure that you only use break statements
and loops and it turns out well since we
have the abstract syntax tree of the
Stan program before we generate Stan
code we can actually do that and so we
have this loop checker thing and Skala
Stan that maintains a number of nested
loops
it starts with an initial state of zero
so there are zero loops and then we have
these increment and decrement functions
to increment and decrement the number of
loops these are actually use this
actually uses a state monad which I
think it's kind of cool to show how that
works just because this is a fun
application of it and you know come up
with those too often it's nice to see I
think applications of things like this
and larger non toy problems I guess so
how many of you are familiar with the
statement there so this it's not gonna
be news that's probably good basically
the goal is just the pass around mutable
state it's not really mutable but it
kind of looks that way without having to
do it at Swiss utley because it's really
annoying to this pass Oh updated one
updated to updated three through
everything so we'd like to make that
nicer so here it's the what a state pipe
looks like it just has a function that
tastes the current state has and then
when you run it it has a return value
and the new state
and basically the idea is we just build
up more complicated versions of that and
then once we have an initial state once
we have the whole graph built up we can
just give it an initial value and say go
and it runs all the state that runs all
the things and this looks like you're
using state it feels like you're using
state but really it's fairly functional
and has all the benefits that that has
so our type checking what's a lot like
this if we have handle while which gets
called for every while loop increment
the number of loops handled while loop
decrement the number of loops is same
for a while and this is just for
comprehensions to update that do this
all in the state monad and then we have
this the functions the handle break and
continue break just says well what's the
current value in the state if it's zero
then I'm not in a loop so I throw this
exception and we can see early on that
the program is not valid and then if it
is valid we continue on and we handle
the break
same with continue and of course all
this stuff is kind of nasty to implement
the type checking and everything is
dirty but the thing is once you've
implemented it hopefully your end users
don't have to worry about that and it
makes life a lot easier for people down
the road and of course with this type of
thing is it's interesting to think of
all the fun things you could do later
with optimizing and doing other
probabilistic programming type things
like not non centered transforms and
things that are really tedious to do and
stand by itself so I mean that's all I
had
basically I talked about a simple
example of probabilistic programming
using Scala Stan why we might what the
advantages of using an embedded
domain-specific language are and how
that simple method using the Scala types
Scala stands open source and it's
available there and Stan is available
also and I highly recommend checking out
the stand stand user manual if nothing
else it's very interesting and if there
are any questions I'll take those
yeah so the question is how is a
probabilistic program fit into the
bigger system so I guess let's I guess
is that like a question of iCal C bode
uses it are so I can't say much for how
many good examples I can give here but
we do use so we have like computer
vision algorithms for example that look
at field say and they try to classify
what's on that field and this is one of
the techniques that we use for that and
I mean it's don't MA get into too many
details I suppose but it's this used for
both learning and running models so
anything else yeah
you
[Music]
yeah so so it is kind of unfortunate I
suppose that basically under the hood
what this is doing is using commands
Stan which actually compiles the model
each well it doesn't file each time
caches the compiled models but when we
ship to production it will actually have
the first time it runs compiled to model
so it will have to have like the Stan
command Stan program and everything
available to it and it runs the model
that way and then we learn the
parameters and use the results Stan uses
the nut sampler to know u-turn sampler
type of HMC anything else
last last talk of the day very exciting
yeah
so the question is is there total parity
with the Stan programming language and
the answer is to the best of my
knowledge I think it is but it's hard
it's hard to know for sure like I'm I
would guess that there are some things
that you can do in stand that you cannot
convince the type system is valid in
Scala Stan I I think most of the
functions are available in both places I
actually just recently added one that
was added in a brand new version of
command Stan so it's difficult to keep
up with that but it's but the base is
there so it's actually not too bad
right
if there's nothing else like us thank
you
[Applause]